ومن عمان تنضموا الينا رولا الامينه
المتحدثه باسم مفوضيه الساميه للامم
المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين في الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا مرحبا بك يا رولا هناك
اسئله كثيره تتعلق بكم من مساعدات التي تم
رزها ولكن بدايه اولى هناك تساؤلات تتعلق
بكيفيه وصول هذه المساعدات بالفعل المشكله
الان التي يفكر فيها الكثيرون ليست في رز
مساعدات بكم كبير ولكن النجاح في وصول هذه
المساعدات للمتضررين
يعني لنكن واقعيين هناك اليات لايصال
المساعدات طبعا هناك تحديات كبيره بسبب
الطقس وبسبب الزلزال وبسبب السياسه ولكن
هناك اليات موجوده وتعتمدها المفوضيه
والوكالات الاغاثه الاخرى منذ سنوات
لايصال المساعدات سواء داخل سوريا في
المناطق التي تحت سلطه الحكومه او في
مناطق التي تسيطر عليها المعارضه نحن
موجودون على الارض في داخل سوريا وقد
تمكنا من ارسال مساعدات طارئه من خيام من
بلاستيكيه بطانيات فرشات الى الاماكن
المتضرره مثل حماه وغيرها وبدانا بالتوزيع
منذ ليله امس في الشمال السوري لدينا
مخزون ولدينا شركاء على المخزون موجود في
الشمال السوري
بمواد اغاثيه مشابهه ولدينا شركاء على
الارض يحاولون الوصول الى معظم المناطق
المتضرره ولكن هناك تحديات طيب رولا يقال
ان الطرق تعوق مساله وصول هذه المساعدات
التقارير اللوجستيه من على الارض كيف تقيم
لك الوضع صحيح وهذا ما كنت اود ان اقوله
هناك تحديات لان الطرق على سبيل المثال
التي تسلكها الشاحنات والسيارات الكبيره
لايصال المساعدات من تركيا الى الشمال
السوري هذه الطرق قد تاثرت بالزلزال خاصه
في الجانب التركي وقد تصدعت فهناك اعتاقات
ويتم العمل عليها في داخل الشمال الغرب
سوريا هناك ايضا
اعاقات في الطرق هناك العاصفه الثلجيه
البارده جدا والقويه جدا والتي ادت ايضا
الى اغلاق بعض الطرق الكهرباء قد انطقم
انقطعت وكذلك الانترنت في معظم الاماكن
لذلك لا يوجد لدينا حتى الان صوره شامله
عن مدى الخسائر الاحتياجات ولكن لدينا
شركاء على الارض موجودون وهم وهذا هو
الوضع عاده موجودون على الارض ويحاولون
الوصول الى الجميع ولكن الموضوع ياخذ وقتا
اكثر مما مفرود ولكن هناك جهود جباره
للوصول الى جميع المنكوبين والاماكن
المتضرره طيب هناك سؤال ربما يدور الان في
الاذان رولا هل تمت اتصالات سياسيه ترعاها
الامم المتحده لتمكين فرق الانقاذ
والمفوضيه الخاصه بالامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين والمساعدات الانسانيه ليفتح لكم
الطريق من الناحيه التواصلات السياسيه
هكذا اقصد
نعم الامم المتحده طبعا انت تعرفين هناك
جهات مختلفه كل يعني بشان معين صحيح
بالنسبه
لفتح معابر اخرى غير باب الهوى وغير التي
تستعمل والتي كانت تستعمل خلال السنوات
القادمه هذا
امر مهم ويجب ان تتضافر الجهود ويجب ان
يتعاون الجميع على توفير كافه السبل
لتامين الاغاثه للذين يحتاجون ساسالك عن
هذه التفاصيل ولكن قولي لي وفقا للتقارير
التي تصل اليك باب الهوى مفتوح ام مغلق
معبر باب الهوى يعني لا اريد ان اقول مغلق
بالكامل لانه هو التباب هو مفتوح ولكن
الطرقات قد تصدعت من جراء الزلزال وهذا
يعني ان الشاحنات الكبيره
والتي كانت تنقل الغذاء لديها صعوبه في
اخذ هذا الطريق خاصه على جانب التركي
المساعدات تصل الى الشمال السوري عبر
تركيا
بقرار من مجلس الامن
باتفاق بين الدول الخمس الموجوده على
المجلس الامن وخاصه الولايات المتحده وهل
يلتزم النظام السوري بهذه القرارات هل
يتعاون في هذا الشان يعني هو النظام
السوري مش موجود على هذه الحدود ولكن
الامم المتحده القرار هو حتى يتيح للامم
المتحده نقل المساعدات عبر الحدود بدون
موافقه الحكومه السوريه هذا هو القرار
اقول
ولكن المعارضه تقول انه من الصعب اصول
المساعدات اذا لم تسمح حكومه بشار الاسد
بدخول هذه المساعدات الى شمال السوري
هناك اليات متعدده نحن كما ايضا نحاول
هناك بعض المساعدات التي تصل من المناطق
التي يسيطر عليها الحكومه السوريه ونسميها
اي هي يعني نعبر خطوط التماس بين مناطق
الحكومه ومناطق المعارضه هذه ايضا نحن
نبحث مع الحكومه وكل الجهات المختصه
لامكانيه زياده دخول المساعدات عن هذا
الطريق لتامين اكبر قدر من المواد
الاغاثيه الى داخل والى شمال غرب سوريا
حيث الحاجه كبيره جدا الحاجه طبعا كبيره
في كل الاماكن التي وصل اليها الزلزال
ونحن ندعو الجميع الى وضع السياسه جانبا
والتركيز على الاحتياجات في الانسانيه
وعدم تسييس المساعدات الانسانيه لان فعلا
كيف تقيمين مستوى الاغاثه وجود الانقاذ
المقدمه الان الى الشمال السوري هل مساومه
منخفض متوسط مطمئن متص
يعني الزلزال حدث يا ليله امس او خلينا
لنقل فجر وهذا يعني ان الوقت يعني ما زال
غير كاتبه نحكم الجميع يحاول جاهدا ان تصل
المساعدات باسرع وقت ممكن ولكن كما قلت
اثار الزلزال والعاصفه طبعا تضامع معوقات
وعوائق جديه امام ادخال المزيد من
المساعدات هناك مساعدات موجوده داخل
الشمال السوري في المخازن وهناك شركاء
الارض يستعملونها لاصالها الى المتضررين
ولكن الاحتياجات كبيره لذلك نقول ان تاتي
مساعدات اخرى والمزيد منها ونحن يعني
نطالب الجميع والمجتمع الدولي والافراد
وشركات الخاصه بالتعاون لارسال المزيد من
المساعده حتى نتمكن من الوصول الى ساسالك
على ما فهمته من ان الاعتماد في جهود
الانقاذ الان يتم على المخزون المتوفر لدى
شركاء في هذه المنظمات على الارض ولكن
اسمحي لنا هناك عرض لبعض التقارير
الانسانيه نجح رجال الخوذه البيضاء في
سوريا بانقاذ طفل علقه تحت ركام المنزل
الذي كان يسكن به وعلى الرغم من اصابته
وبقائه تحت الانقاض لساعات طويله الا ان
فرق الانقاذ اكدت ان الطفل تم اخراجه وهو
بصحه جيده
يعمل
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
الحمد لله على السلامه يا عمو
[موسيقى]
شوي شوي على الحديد
تمام تمام الله يجزيكم يا رب بسم الله
الله اكبر ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
روح روح روح
[موسيقى]
وهذه هي طبيعه الكوارث الانسانيه اختلاط
ما بين الموت والنجامه بين الموت والحياه
اعود مره اخرى الى عمان الى الاستاذه رولا
الامينه المتحدثه باسم المفوضيه الساميه
للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين في الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا رولا من المبكر
الحديث عن احصائيات تتعلق بالناجين او
المتضررين ولكن هناك تساؤلات تتعلق
بالارقام المتوقعه بشان الاطفال لان هناك
عدد كبير من الصور والفيديوهات تتعلق
بالاطفال
لا استطيع ان اتنبا برقم الان ولكن لاننا
لا نستطيع ليس فقط المفوضيه بالجميع
وكالات الاغاثه من الوصول الى جميع
المناطق المنكوبه يصعد تحديد رقم ولكن
نتوقع ان الارقام عن الخسائر البشريه
والدمار ستزداد وهذا للاسف طبعا يعني
الوضع المحسن وكارثي جدا جدا جدا ولهذا
نناشد الجميع في عدم تاحه المجال للسياسه
للوقوف امام الاغاثه الانساني يجب ان
نتذكر ان الشعب السوري المدنيين يدفعون
الثمن الاكبر منذ 12 سنه في هذه والان هم
يدفعون هذا الثمن مضاعفه لذلك يجب ان نكون
هناك التزام بمساعدتهم بغض النظر اين هم
والى من ينتمون ومن
يسيطرات لمجلس الامن تلزم الجميع بضروره
تامين وصول المساعدات الى المتضررين بغض
النظر عن اي حدود او اتفاقيات سياسيه اخرى
يعني هناك قرار منذ عام
2014 هناك قرار من مجلس الامن بتمكين
الامم المتحده من ادخال المساعدات عبر
التركيه الى الشمال غرب سوريا ولكن افراد
الامم المتحده غير مخورين بالدخول يعني
نحن نرسل الشاحنات ونرسل مواد الاغاثه
والقيام والبطانيات والغذاء كله عبر تركيا
ولكن لدينا شركاء على الارض سوريون
ومنظمات اغاثه دوليه غير متابعه للامم
المتحده هي من يقوم بالتوزيع هذه الاليه
اوسخ سمح فيها مجلس الامن وعلى اساسها يتم
ادخالها هذه المساعده
تتم حسب السياسه
يعني اتفاق الدول الكبرى على هذا القرار
والذي
اتخذ بعض المفاوضات
التركيه قال اليوم في تصريحاته انه سيقوم
بتقديم المساعدات بغض النظر عن اي خلافات
سياسيه ولكن قبل التقرير كنت اسالك رولا
عن المساعدات هل نجحت مساعدات جديده في
الدخول بالفعل الى الشمال السوري ام انكم
تعتمدون على مخزون المساعدات المتوافر لدى
الشركاء على الارض وهو مخزون سابق وليس
لاحق لهذه الكارثه
صحيح حتى الان وحسب ما اعرف
الاعتماد الان على المخزون الموجود نحن
نعمل على ادخال المزيد ولكن يجب ان نتذكر
ان الارضيه هذا الزلزال حدث وكان نقطه
الوسط فيه هي مدينه غازي منطقه غازي عنتاب
وهذه المنطقه التي يتخذها جميع الوكالات
الاغاثه ووكالات الامم المتحده
كموقع قيادي
يعني كبيت لهم حتى يتمكنوا من تنسيق
المساعدات وادخالها الى الشمال السوري
فحتى زملائنا قد تهدمت بيوتهم ومكاتبهم
وهم يعملون من خلال سياراتهم او في الوقت
في يعني في العرب لانهم لا يستطيعون ان
يذهبوا الى مكاتبهم فاليه اتقال المساعدات
الى الشمال الغربي من سوريا كلها قد تاثرت
بهذا
يعني هناك محاولات كما قلت لك مثلا الطريق
الذي تاثر على الجانب التركي هناك يعني
محاولات حديثه لاصلاحه باسرع وقت ممكن حتى
تتمكن الشاحنات من استعماله والدخول لذلك
كان يقال يوسف الطرق دائما بانها شريان
الحياه لان من خلال هذه الطرق يتم توصيل
المساعدات اسمحي لنا ان نشير الى هذا
العاجل المركز السوري يقول ان عدد ضحايا
الزلزال في سوريا تجاوز الالفي قتيل هذا
هو الرقم الاخير ايضا هناك ارقام تتعلق
بارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال ايضا في عموم
سوريا الى هذا الرقم وفقا للمرصد السوري
قتيل
رولا بخبرتك الدوليه في هذا المجال
بالتاكيد زلزال من هذا النوع وسط ظروف
متغيره للغايه مزيد من الارتدادات الارضيه
مستمره او الهزات الارتداديه الطقس السيء
للغايه تقطع الطرق جهود الاغاثه يمكن ان
تاخذ شهور
لا يجب ان لا تاخذ شهور ولا اسابيع الوضع
لا يحتمل ان تاخذ اسابيع ولا ايام يعني
نحن هناك شركاء لنا ووكلات الامم المتحده
الاخرى الكل يعمل جاهدا ربما يستطيعون
ارسال بعض المساعدات غدا صباحا لذلك لا
نريد التحويل بان الانسان هذه اخبار جيده
للغايه انتم تحاولون انا عم بقول انا مش
عم بقول راح يصير بكره الصبح انا بقول ما
عندي وقت بقدر اقول فيه ولكن بالتاكيد
ليست المساله مساله شهور وبالتاكيد ليست
مساله اسابيع وربما غدا ربما بعد غد لا
اعتقد ان الامر يحتمل اكثر من ذلك طيب هل
لديكم اتصالات بالمكتب السياسيه الامين
العام للامم المتحده تحوطون علما بتطورات
بان هناك صعوبات تواجهكم في جهود الانقاذ
حتى يتم اتصال سياسي او تنسيق ماء او عقد
جلسه لمجلس الامن لاتخاذ قرارات بهذا
الامر لابد ان تتحرك السياسه ايضا على
الجانب الاخر عبر تقارير تصدر منكم هكذا
يتوقع البعض
يعني الامين العام قد تحدث في الموضوع منذ
اول يوم
وهو على ايصال المساعدات وعلى تامين
المساعدات وتامين التمويل لارسال
المساعدات وانا متاكده انهم يبحثون مع
جميع الاطراف كيفيه حل كل وتجاوز كل هذه
العقبات لا اتحدث انا مع الامين العام
ولكن جميع وكالات الامام المتحده تنصف
وهناك مكتب تنسيق الاغاثه مكتب مخصص
لتنسيق جميع الجهود الاغاثه للداخل السوري
وفي اي مكان في العالم وهم جميعا بتعاون
وثيق ومعرفه وثيقه مع مكتب الامين العام
وجميع المسؤولين عن الوضع هل تواجهون
صعوبات هل تتمكنوا هل هناك عوائق انت
تعلمين اكثر مني طبعا هناك تنسيق تامهم
يعلمون ويعملون على تجاوز هذه العقبات
يعني لا نريد ان نهول ايضا من
لا نريد ان نعطي صوره وكانه لا يوجد اغاثه
لان الزملائي موجودون على الارض موجودون
على الارض في داخل سوريا وموجودين في غازي
عنتاب يجب ان نتذكر كذلك انه حتى في تركيا
في المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال هناك الاف
وعشرات الانوثه من اللاجئين السوريين وهم
ايضا تاثروا وهم ايضا خسروا عائلاتهم وهم
ايضا
فالاغال تتصل الى كل من نستطيع الوصول
اليه ولكن حينما يكون هناك
كارثه كان زلزال حتى جهود الاغاثه تتعثر
وهذا يحدث في اي مكان في العالم وليس فقط
اشكرك رولا الامين المتحدثه باسم المفوضيه
الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين في
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا تحياتي